foreign congress like the presidential
election still
too close to call at this hour democrats
have kept the house but are unlikely to
expand the majority
despite predictions of continuing 2018's
blue wave
and a possible flip in the senate at
least a handful of democrats in
states president trump won in 2016 lost
and several republicans targeted for
flips by democrats
held on to their seats our washington
correspondent jesse turner reports
we still have a majority that's
important congressman steve cohen joins
a large pool of house democrats to win
back their seats
but republicans were able to oust some
of their colleagues
i was disappointed in the overall house
results i thought it would be anybody's
members cohen attributes the smaller
margin to democrats being overly
optimistic
and republicans responding well to
accusations made by president trump
about democrat policies the president
says are socialist
he gave the people what they wanted to
hear house republicans who won
re-election like tennessee congressman
tim burchett
credit the same thing for not only
holding on to seats democrats targeted
but also flipping seats black folks with
hispanic folks
go down the list and people people want
to succeed they don't want more taxes
and they don't want more government but
burgett says the election also shows why
democrats need to revamp their strategy
the old folks just don't get it you know
they're all it's not barbecue and
bluegrass anymore
while control of the senate still hangs
in the balance on thursday afternoon
burchett and cohen were both optimistic
about the presidency
but from different sides i think it's
going to end up in the courts regardless
joe biden's going to be president
in washington i'm jesse tannor